buenos días los ministros de exteriores
del g-7 han instado a irán para que
avance en las negociaciones que se
realizan en viena en austria para
revivir el acuerdo nuclear de 2015 la
ministra de exteriores a la
alemana anna-lena barba quien ha hecho
su debut internacional en esta cumbre
dijo que el tiempo se está acabando y
que la posición actual de irán ha hecho
que las negociaciones se devuelvan por
lo menos seis meses es decir que no hay
avances entretanto el gobierno británico
dijo que irán todavía tiene tiempo para
llegar a ese acuerdo tan esperado y
también se ha hablado de posibles nuevas
sanciones económicas a irán lo cierto y
lo que podemos esperar para esta tarde
cuando la cumbre de ministros de
exteriores baje su telón en esta
declaración final es un llamado a irán
para que modere su lenguaje su programa
nuclear
lo ha dicho riders y además para que se
siente en esas mesas de negociación y
pueda avanzar
de exigirle a rusia como avanzadas el
respeto territorial para ucrania ante la
posibilidad de una invasión